all right Thank You Marci
so hello Cascadia Jas welcome to this
talk how many people are feeling drowsy
after lunch shine some light on these
people right here we want to make sure
that I asked a few questions during my
talk wake people up alright so for the
next half an hour or so I'm going to
pretend to know a few things about
JavaScript but like Marcy said I do
security research so hopefully you'll go
along with the facade and not call me
out if I say something wrong but but I
spend my time looking at malware and I
thought I could share some of the
JavaScript malware that we've been
seeing lately in on the internet in the
wild so this talk is called Raiders or
the JavaScript based malware all right
so the two important threats that I
wanted to discuss is an example of a
ransomware
that is written entirely in JavaScript
which is which is something we didn't
even know could happen as security
researchers because we always see
ransomware written in C or C++ one of
those languages right
but this ransomware is written entirely
in JavaScript the second thing second
important thing we want to discuss was
crypto jacking and crypto jacking is
proliferating on the Internet and what
we want to discuss a little bit about
that as well
so let's go ahead and get started a
little bit about me a little bit about
our group I work as part of the security
research group at Michigan State
University before I was a PhD candidate
there before I started my PhD there I
used to do independent penetration
testing so you know finding flaws
security weaknesses for clients and then
getting them a report at the end of it
so that they can fix the security holes
so I am an active speaker at security
conferences this is the first time I'm
speaking at a conference which is not a
security conference so this is pretty
exciting for me and a little
nerve-wracking but but so this slide
kind of introduces some of the threats
some of the new stories that I've seen
over the past week so these are pretty
recent
so Ransom it's not ransomware is not
going anywhere you know financially
motivated cyber criminals love to use
rants
we're encrypted jackin attacks to make
the money and it's not going anywhere
because because it keeps making them
money so why would they
you know discard of this amazing method
they have to to make money and and
what's new is we is is the JavaScript
based ransomware that we've just seen so
the the elements of a ransomware before
I go ahead and jump into the JavaScript
based ransomware called Raa ransomware
and focus on the code and the JavaScript
details of the JavaScript and while
there I want to discuss the basic
elements of a ransomware so it starts
with an initial entry right so just like
any other infection you want to gain an
entry into the host so there's a bunch
of ways to do that I'm sure all of you
are familiar with social engineering
attacks you know so you know traditional
phishing emails they have a document
attached if you if you get an
unsuspecting you know user to download
and double click it then it executes the
malicious functionality on their system
right and then there are other ways that
we've seen recently which they're
they're using which is exporting known
vulnerabilities if you're not updating
your PC's regularly and they also love
to exploit weakly secured RDP sessions
or Isis s sessions if you if you haven't
got got a strong password on there and
and that sort of thing so the next thing
they need to do is get an encryption
secret which means that all right they
need to have a unique key per victim if
for every infection they need to have a
unique key why because you're a part of
their big ransomware campaign and if
they have the same key for every victim
then vicked once a victim pays let's say
300 dollars for for the ransom and gets
the key back then that key can be shared
with the rest of the users and that
neutralizes the entire ransomware
campaign so it's important for them to
get this unique encryption secret per
victim right and then and then they go
ahead and start with file encryption so
they search for specific file types they
don't want to encrypt dll's
that doesn't do them any good because
you can just restore that but what you
cannot restore which is your personal
data so if you don't have a backup right
so they are looking to encrypt docx
xlsx and so that's that sort of thing so
you know they they like to
finally they like to demand ransom which
is usually around $300 in
cryptocurrencies so with the
understanding of the general elements of
ransomware let's take a look at our AAA
ransomware so this is the first
ransomware like I said like I've said
that's written entirely in JavaScript
and it uses the default windows script
host now I did not know that by default
Windows has the windows script host
which is a scripting engine that
executes JavaScript on Windows so if a
user so what they do is they send a
phishing email to a user and the
attachment is something likes something
underscore doc underscored dot je s now
the users users are generally trained to
think that it's normally exe s or
executable files that are malicious so
they would they're more likely to
download a J's file thinking that it's
benign right so they'll don't download
it and then double clicking it means
that windows script host will execute it
all right so now now that they have
execution capability on host then they
use a bunch of JavaScript obfuscation
tactics because in case of c and c++ the
code isn't always visible you have to
the source code is invisible to us as
malware analysts but in case of
JavaScript the source code is right
there so for that reason they want to
make it hard for us to understand what's
going on and for that reason they use a
lot of obfuscation tactics which
basically means they break anything
you've learned about coding standards
and good coding practices they do the
opposite of that so it makes it
difficult to read this one likes to add
insult to injury this is not a primary
functionality of a ransomware but this
one likes to also drop a Trojan in the
background that spies on you and steals
your information so you know no ethics
in the cyber criminal you know in the
cyber criminal world anymore like what's
the world coming to
so these are these are what we call
indicators of compromise which means
these are symptoms of an infection in
the security industry we like to you
know use these as a metric towards okay
do you have this specific in in you know
infection so a primary way to do it is
to look at hashes in this particular J's
file these are the sha
and md5 hashes that are you know that
indicate that okay you're hit with this
particular ransomware then you can look
at drop files so once it once it
executes on a system you can see the
files it drops in this particular case
it drops st dot exe which is that pony
trojan that steals your information so
that's another indicator and then
network activity it makes a dns request
to start wave now calm which is its
command and control server i'll be
discussing that in a little bit but
that's where it goes to for commands so
once you execute this what I'm going to
do is I'm going to show you the system
impact and then I'll discuss the
JavaScript code that leads to that
system impact so this is the process
graph once you execute it W scripts dot
exe is the window scripting host that I
was talking about and that basically
creates two processes WordPad exe and st
dot exe su dot exe is the Tony the pony
Trojan that I was talking about and warp
at that exe just puts a diversion screen
in front of your face which distracts
you while it's executing malicious
functionality in the background so this
is the example this is that diversion
screen that I was talking about it's in
Russian you know a big surprise there
it's so this is an error code they are
basically telling users that you know
this particular version of Microsoft
Word or whatever cannot open this
document for this reason so while you're
busy dealing with that and while you're
trying to click close it jumps around so
when you try to get to the close button
it jumps around so while you're trying
to figure out how can I close this
particular window it executes malicious
functionality in the background so and
it doesn't need a lot of time to do that
a few seconds is enough a network
activity in the meanwhile you know in
the in the meantime network activity
something like this it makes several
requests to DNS requests to start with
na komm which is its command and control
server and it's the potential source of
the unique encryption key that I was
talking about when I was talking about
the primary elements of ransomware
so that's where it acquires its unique
encryption key from right but the CNC
server
in case of many of these infections the
malicious domains get taken
obviously once they're recognized so
this particular CNC server has been
taken down now so we can't really study
what response it gets back to from the
server anymore but if you look at the
code so two of the things that I didn't
show was it then encrypts the files so
if it let's say if it found your docx or
your xlsx it will then replace that with
an encrypted version and then what it
will do next is you know have a ransom
note in every folder of your computer so
you know because having a ransom note on
one computer isn't enough so it's on one
folder isn't enough so it just goes
ahead and in every folder you have
you've got on your computer it will put
a ransom note up there so so crypto j/s
library is a big part of this ransomware
we've seen that ransomware developers
are [ __ ] at coding so well so what they
do is they engage in a lot of cargo
called programming they steal code from
each other they copy paste code from
let's say wiki CPP and things like that
so they already can't get many things
right so why would they want to
implement crypto functionality from
scratch because there's a lot of room
for error there so what they do is they
use some kind of cryptographic library
in this particular case they use the
crypto JS library so the first 800 lines
of this ransomware contains the crypto
JS code has just copy paste in so that's
where it gets its crypto functionality
from now the next part is the the
diversion message so the the message
that I showed you on the screen on
WordPad Exe in Russian that comes from
here so if you look at this part right
here by the way also notice the code
obfuscation here the function names and
the variable names there they're very
difficult to read they're just a bunch
of random characters so that makes it
hard for you to follow along with their
code so in this particular function this
variable holds a long string which is
you know then basics before decoded and
then it drops this particular you know
decoded string in my documents then
creates this doc underscore attached
underscore a random string
and and then puts it in front of your
face by opening WordPad Exe and pasting
this on there so that's what that
diversion screen was all right so then
we talked about decrypting the Pony
Trojan because like I said st dot exe is
pertains to the pony trojan that spies
on your information right so this
function is responsible for creating
that and this is pretty impressive
because they use JavaScript to create a
binary executable file by and by
encoding and encrypting the whole binary
in the in string format in there so it's
hard coded in there so what it does is
this is the this is a very long string
by the way it's truncated over here but
it's a very long string which contains
the entire code for Pony troyzan and
then and then it decrypt it by using the
AES encryption algorithm or decryption
algorithm and then and then the the key
for that is also encoded as part of the
ransomware and then it uses that eval
command to basically get to this point
so that eval evaluates to over here and
so this is what it evaluates to and this
is what drops the Pony Trojan where it
goes in the my documents' creates that
file SP dot exe which is the trojan and
the care set 437 pertains to well it
lets it figure out how to handle this
executable binary data in string format
so that's what that pertains to you'll
see that throughout this ransomware is
code and then you see write text safety
file close that file
so obviously it's creating that file now
on in the My Documents folder and then
finally it runs the file so now the
trojan is executing on your computer
next thing it needs to do is now it
needs to actually perform its ransomware
functionality which is to encrypt drives
so to do that
what it does is it uses the basic object
available as part of the windows script
host to create to go through the drives
and enumerate the drives drive letters
and then access different files and
folders and you know source through the
files and their extensions to know which
files to encrypt and so on
so you'll see things like this else
continue and then there's this is the
equivalent of a go-to statement you know
and this makes this code further
complicated to understand because this
makes it a spaghetti code if they have a
bunch of random go to jumps at random
spots
it makes us hard to follow along the the
execution flow of up there of their by
of their code so further off the station
tactics that they use the ransom note
comes from here and and then this for
change to encrypting the users files
which which means that this particular
function right here calls this function
in a loop once for every file that it
wants to encrypt so this particular
function that is called in the loop
within the other function will be
encrypting each and every file going
through deriving functionality from the
crypto JS library that's that I showed
you in the beginning and you know they
use the AES encryption algorithm to do
this so a quick summary you know it
obviously encrypts files on the user's
computer on the user's computer but it
also deletes VSS files what I didn't
show you for the sake of brevity is it
also performs certain others has like
deleting VSS files these are volumes
shadow copies that are maintained on
windows so you know you can use Windows
Restore to restore to an earlier point
so if you do that obviously ransomware
has lost its leverage on you so what
what they like to do is make sure they
eliminate any backups in any form so
because of that they want to get rid of
those VSS volume shadow copies so it
likes to do that as well like I said it
drops true you know the Trojan horse
which is not which is not really
something every ransomware does but this
one does so so that's unique to this
ransomware and and the Trojan is dropped
in My Documents folder so you know in in
summary it was very interesting for us
as malware analysts to see the
there's a ransomware now written
entirely in JavaScript I mean who knew
that javascript is a full-blown
programming language you know so that so
the next threat is scripted right Jackie
and I want to quickly touch upon this as
well because this is the second biggest
thing we're seeing in 2018 so ransomware
has been you know continuing since 2005
2006 is when it took off and now it's
steadily growing right but cryptid
jacking took off after following the
rise in the valuation of
cryptocurrencies so around the end of
2017 Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
took off and and so of course it took
other cryptocurrencies like maneras
valuation up with it and then we are
introduced to web crypto jacking and and
it's the unauthorized use of processing
power and electricity to mine
cryptocurrencies so if you go on a
website I'll show you the web examples
of this because that is more relevant to
JavaScript and so so the web-based
examples of this would be something like
this where you'll go on a website and if
you look through the source code you'll
see a little script being called from
coin Hyper's of particular is a popular
source for these scripts where they'll
import the script from coin hive and it
will initiate a coin hive instance in
the browser and that is the that that
number that unique string you see in the
box is the ID of the attacker and that
is where you know it credits all the all
the money so you mind
you're basically mining for someone else
while you're visiting this web page so
you can see how it can get lucrative if
you have thousands and thousands of
visitors visiting on your website and
say staying on that web page for a long
amount of time so how do you do that how
do you do that you you just you just
give that you just tell them that
there's like HD porn free HD porn on
this on this link and people will click
it's amazing so you know
so here we go
so you know scripts as seen on the
crypto jackin websites more examples of
that this one is an example with crypto
loot doing the same thing so it's not
just coin hive it's sometimes also
crypto loot and there's other sources as
well so what are the impact on on system
resources alright we did a little
experiment just to see how much what
they do and this was when this threat
was very new so just the beginning of
2018 so you know that's the that's the
before and after shot and you know
before you see that the course you know
that this the computer is at normal
usage and then you visit one website you
know one web page with this crypto
jacking script enabled in the background
and you see that all four cores are now
being used 200 percent of their capacity
and the CPU temperature rises and and if
you look at the top process is the web
content that's draining ninety seven
point five percent of your CPU power
right now which is you know kind of
stupid of them because this makes it
really easy to notice but they'll get
cleverer and that's what that's what the
problem is that is they're they're in a
learning phase right now at least as far
as crypto jacking attacks are concerned
so they will figure out that it's better
to mind slower and you know get away
with it for a long duration than to do
something like this where you'll
probably notice it pretty quickly
because your computer slows down as well
you know you're draining electricity and
you know that sort of thing so you know
it this is more obvious then we see
examples like this so in this particular
case if you look at the source code of
the website you won't really see right
away where the cryptid jacking script is
hidden so if you're looking for coin
high or crypto loot or some one of those
other you know miners you won't really
see it right away but there's that eval
function again I I recently read
something about evil isn't evil it's
just misunderstood yeah right you know I
see see it and ransomware seen in crypto
jackin so so this is the this is that
eul function taken from the taken from
the source code and this is what it
evaluates to so again as you can see
it's it's the it's the same old coin
hive script
it's importing and mining on people's
computer and and the problem with this
is that now if you want to help by
writing a crawler or something that
crawls the web looking for different
cryptid jacking websites and let's say
that the string you put in there is look
for coin hive and crypto loot and things
like that
this makes it harder for you to get
there because you know now that now it's
hidden behind this eval statements how
would you write that curie you know how
would you how would you make an
automatic analysis towards you know if
if there's you know crypto jacking on
this website or not so that that makes
it a little more complicated so i did a
preliminary analysis basically i was
looking to crawl the internet looking
for what websites are involved encrypted
jacking and that sort of thing it didn't
go very well because there's a lot a lot
of roadblocks but what i was able to do
is identify using automated analysis
identify 212 websites involved encrypted
jacking and what i wanted to do is
resolve these categories resolve these
websites to category see what kind of
categories are involved more likely to
get involved encrypted jacking so if you
visit a website and it's crypto jacking
is it a pornographic website or you know
is it a is it already serving other
kinds of malware or what kind of website
is that so for that i used for forty
guard has forty guard web filter
categorizes websites in several
categories like you know pornography and
you see the examples in that little
chart i'm showing so so what it does it
curious so that little Python script on
the right it Curie's the forty guard
server for a particular websites once
I've determined that this website is
cryptid jacking then I resolve it to a
particular category and then see how
many we can find you know a lot a lot of
them in already are malicious websites a
lot of them are pornography websites and
that sort of thing but there's a lot of
problems like I said during this
analysis because you how do you crawl
the web that's a big task so for that
what I did was I utilized public.www
nerdy data senses they've already got
caches maintained where they because
they already have crawlers that are
crawling the the internet looking for
webpages and they're looking at web
pages and there's
was codes so if you just curious you
don't have to write your own crawler
which is take which would take forever
so okay we can kind of get away with
doing that but how do we determine the
unauthorized part during this automated
automated analysis right because there's
legitimate uses of cryptocurrency mining
on a webpage for example there's an
example of a website where they're
asking to donate to charity by clicking
on you know stark mining and then
staying on that page and you can then
donate money to charity that way so we
obviously don't want to include that on
the cryptid jacking so how do we
determine the unauthorized part that
requires manual analysis to see if
they're seeking permission from the user
somewhere so that makes it more
complicated so then how do we validate
the results some websites are now
unavailable so you can some web sites
have cleaned their source code so an
obfuscation how do we get around code
obfuscation like I showed that eval
statement so if you're just looking for
coin hype or crypto loot scripts or
things like that then you know if
they've got a they've got a clever eval
statement over there then it doesn't
work that way so maybe there's another
better way of doing this that you know
you guys can figure out so you know in
in conclusion there's probably better
ways to discover crypto jacking websites
on the on the Internet
this is not really my area to write you
know a lot of web crawling scripts and
you know determining maybe there's a
better way that you guys can think of
and talk to me about of doing this and
you know maybe we can protect our users
better so you know some people are
coming with coming up with browser based
extensions that automatically block all
cryptocurrency mining and but they don't
always work so there's maybe you know
some room there for improvement and we
have to stay a step ahead of the
attackers because that's what we do in
the security industry is the constant
cat and mouse game and so we have to
determine like this Windows script using
the windows script host to execute a
JavaScript based malware is something we
did not really see coming so what are
the other possibilities where they can
use you know JavaScript for malicious
purposes because if we can figure that
out ahead of time then we can maybe
think about you know working around that
so and like I said
for the cleverer ransomware encrypted
jacking attacks are the future where
they won't mind hundred percent you know
100 percent of your CPU they'll be more
subtle and sometimes we've seen
instances where what they do is they
open up a so when you go to a particular
website and they're cryptic jacking you
they open us a window in the background
and then they make it really small and
then they hide it under the under the
taskbar next to the next to the clock
and and so even if you closed the
original web page or used that other
webpage is still open and continuously
mining and you never notice it so until
the next time you shut down your
computer that's mining for them so
they're getting more cleverer by the day
so we want us to stay a step ahead of
them so yeah if you've got any ideas you
know please get in touch and this is
just a quick introduction to you know
two big problems and and I would love to
talk to you more about that so thank you
very much